the opening scene begins with two men
who are surveying an area of the
Appalachia Cola National Forest in leyon
County Florida while mapping out a
specific area one of the surveyors finds
his device stuck in the ground he tries
to pull it out only to discover some
traces of blood which leaves him
perplexed seconds later he notices an
entity with red glowing eyes terrified
he tries to run away but the unknown as
salent pulls him away and kills him
seeing this the other surveyor sets off
in a panic prompting him to run away and
hide behind a fallen tree but
unfortunately he too Falls victim to
this red eyed creature it's just me with
a hangover scet later in the day a man
named Michael asov and his son Louis are
seen hunting for possums with their dog
bow in the same stretch of woods in the
midst of this they come across a surve's
bloodstained jacket raising alarm
sensing an imminent danger Michael
orders his son to take bow and run
straight home without stopping for
anything in the meantime he loads his
shotgun with two bullets before
cautiously heading for inspection as
Lewis and the dog make their way home
they hear Two Shots from the Deep Woods
the dog growls and tries to run back the
way they just came but the boy stops IT
despite being worried for his father
Lewis decides to follow his orders and
refrains from turning back on the other
hand we see two FBI special agents Fox
Moulder and Dana Scully who are car
pooling with their fellow agents Michael
Kinsley and Carla ston Cipher on their
way to a leadership and team building
seminar mder appears to be uncomfortable
and somewhat annoyed by the perky nature
of Agents Kinsley and stun Cipher much
to his relief they are stopped at a
roadblock by local police taking
advantage of the break mder instantly
steps out of the car to stretch his body
guys are pissing me off scl not long
after he is approached by Michael's wife
who informs him about the gunshots in
the woods and subsequent disappearance
of her husband the woman seems frantic
because no one is telling her what
happened to her husband Moulder assures
her that he will look into it and heads
deeper into the woods followed by Skully
there they meet more police officers led
by Officer Michelle fakas investigating
the case officer fakas informs the FBI
agents that they have not found
Michael's body but have some evidence of
a shooting in addition he asserts that
it looks more like an animal attack case
as the forest is inhabited by Wild
animals like Panthers and bearss
Panthers the [__] after Gathering
detailed information about the incident
Moulder decides to stay as it would be a
perfect opportunity to ditch the seminar
he and Scully then check into a nearby
Motel to spend the night later malder is
engaged in researching wild animals when
Scully enters the room with some food he
explains to her that no species native
to North America will attack a stronger
prey when there is a weaker Target
available so it makes no sense that an
animal would go after Michael and ignore
his young son in response Scully simply
brushes off the topic and suggests that
he leave the case in the hands of local
police however Moulder ignores her and
Ventures into the darkness to gather
some more information meanwhile at the
asov residence Lewis confides in his
mother that he suspects his father is
dead he reasons that his father was a
great shooter and if he had hit what he
was shooting at he would have been home
by now despite ls's concerns his mother
asks him to stay strong and think
positive a short while later Bo becomes
agitated and starts barking while
looking outside seeing this Mrs asof
lets him out for a while why why but
when she attempts to bring him back in
he refuses to budge as a result she
decides to head back inside alone only
to find out that the door has been shut
and locked from the inside concerned for
her son's safety she frantically screams
causing the boy to wake up as he gets
out of bed he is startled by a dark dark
shadowy figure with red eyes coming
after him terrified Lewis narrowly
escapes through the doggy door and runs
into Moulder ah doggy style my favorite
he quickly tells him that the creature
is inside the house the next morning the
police officers are on the scene Moulder
shows Scully some tracks inside the
house that appear to be human based on
the weight distribution however he
deduces that the as salent travels on
the balls of its feet rather than from
Heel To Toe I know both BS when I see
them Scully he also speculates that
these creatures are paranormal in nature
in order to back up his claim he points
out how the creature killed three grown
men disposed of their bodies and
strategically lured the mother outside
of the house in order to get to Lewis
later on officer Ficus malder and Scully
decide to venture into the woods in
search of the creature they are
accompanied by local technician Jeff
Glazer who is armed with a
forward-looking infrared or Fleer device
before starting their expedition officer
fakas cautions them about the vastness
of the forest and the lack of mobile
signal coverage due to this she
instructs everyone to stay close and
maintain visual contact in the event
that anyone gets lost she asks them to
stay where they are assuring that she
will find them as they proceed forward
officer Ficus strategically places white
stones to mark their path in order to
help them find their way back later but
unbeknownst to them the Unseen creature
removes all of these markers intending
to trap them in the forest after a while
of walking they detect two creatures on
the fle radar which travel in separate
directions prompting the group to split
up officer fakas and Scully head in One
Direction while the other two guys run
in the opposite direction during this
officer fakas is suddenly attacked and
pulled away seeing this Scully calls out
to the rest of the crew members but by
this time fakas is nowhere to be found
malder deduces that the creature
deliberately separated them to launch
their attack after this incident Glazer
suggests that they Retreat and come back
with more backup mder asserts that the
more they delay the less chance they
have of finding fakas however Scully
agrees with Glazer and convinces him to
return pointing out their lack of
preparation on their way back Moulder
theorizes that the creatures might be
related to Cryptids such as the Moth Man
bang on mder you freaking genius after
walking for a while Glazer claims that
this is not the right way they have not
found any white stones left by Officer
fakas their discussion is suddenly
interrupted when Scully spots a movement
nearby Glazer immediately uses his
device and locates something following
this malder walks towards it with a gun
in his hand while Glazer guides him he
soon sees a humanoid figure hiding
behind a tree and opens fire however the
creature runs away and charges towards
Scully upon seeing the movement she
fires multiple shots until the move
movement stops in the meantime Glazer
who is frightened by these encounters
flees from the scene but sadly his
Escape is cut short as he is caught by
the creature and dragged away now that
they are low on bullets mder advises
Scully not to shoot unless she is
certain of hitting the target she asks
if he saw the creature to which he
replies in the negative however he does
acknowledge that these unseen as salant
are smarter than them it's not saying
much Scully but I think it's true
moments later mder is grabbed by the
creature but before it can drag him away
Scully manages to wound it with her
firearm this prompts it to retreat for
the time being eventually it gets dark
and the two agents are forced to spend
the night in the forest the injured
malder feels cold so Scully tries to
ignite a campfire but fails miserably
she even uses gunpow to do it but to no
avail as a result she holds him in her
lap and Cuddles him to provide the
warmth in order to help stay awake mder
asks her to sing a song for him despite
her initial reluctance she starts to
sing a sadly uninspired rendition of Joy
to the world that's my favorite Scully
thank you the following morning mder
wakes up to find Scully searching for
food unfortunately she falls into a hole
ending up in an underground chamber
malder rushes to check on her and is
relieved when she assures him that she
is fine upon getting up she starts to
look around and is startled by a
disturbing sight the bodies of the
missing people are stor there including
the bodies of Officer Ficus and Michael
a few moments later she also spots a
pair of red glowing eyes which makes her
realize that she is trapped with one of
the creatures sensing the danger she
proceeds to reach for her gun but
realizes that she has dropped her weapon
somewhere she promptly notifies malder
who then drops his gun towards her
before jumping into the hole as the
creature charges towards her she opens
fire and successfully guns it down
following this the two examined the dead
creature and are shocked to discover
that it possesses almost humanlike
features albeit with a woodlike texture
to its skin nearby they discover the
Latin words ad noctem carved into a tree
trunk which means Into Darkness they
Forest dwarves or some [__] Scully
shortly after agents ston Cipher and
Kinsley with police and toe locate
Moulder and Scully they then rescue the
two FBI special agents officer fakas and
Michael from the hole but there is still
no sign of glazer upon leaving the
forest Kinsley remarks that they got all
the credit even though Scully and malder
did all the work he also shows malder a
Crosscut of a tree with various dates
inscribed on the Rings seeing this
malder states that the creatures May in
fact be the evolved versions of the
first Spanish conquistadors who had
settled in the forest 450 years earlier
according to him these conquistadors
have adapted to life in this forest and
they are acting aggressively out of a
need to defend their territory from
encroachment Moulder that sounds
ridiculous just roll with it Scully come
on just then an officer reveals that the
body of the creature Scully shot down
earlier has mysteriously vanished and
that they have been unable to locate it
this makes mder suspect that Scully is
in danger upon learning that she has
returned to the motel alone he grabs a
car and rushes to her meanwhile at the
hotel room Scully is seen packing up her
and Mal's belongings not long after
there is a knock on the door and it is
Moulder after ascertaining that she has
finished packing he firmly urges her to
vacate the room which she does with a
baffled expression on her face the
episode ends as the camera pans under
the bed where a pair of glowing eyes
opens it's a [__] Conquistador Skully
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching